imagine knowing you could do something
that no one else could do you got live I
think we have a
window Diana niad is back you got to
live I know the world wants me to shut
my mouth and sit down and wait to die
but I
can't I want to start with chaien and
Jimmy because this is your narrative
feature film debut as directors you're
obviously known for your work and in the
documentary medium with free solo and
the rescue you had you been looking to
make a narrative feature and what made
this the perfect story to start
with um Jiffy and I have always been
kind of attracted to these stories about
individuals who push the limits of
what's possible it's kind of like this
essential human kind of trait and we had
long been thinking about like what would
that because our our previous films
really centered around men what would
that look like in a woman and when we
first read um the script for niad we
were just like this is exactly that and
it was also an incredible opportunity to
create two very rich roles for two of
the best actresses of their generation
but this one was just most of the events
had already transpired there was a great
documentary made by um Diana and nad's
um nephew called the other Shore where
you see a lot of the archive in the film
it's all about story for us and so when
we find a story that we're both
passionate about and our interests
intersect that that's how we kind of
choose the projects that we work on and
this this story was that Julie on
writing the script um I know you had
Diana's book find a way can you talk
about the choice to like really focus on
first of all this beautiful relationship
between Diana and Bonnie and and did you
have them both as resources as well I
did and on top of the thrilling elements
and The Stranger Than Fiction details of
the adventure it really was this
relationship that got me excited about
this project these two fascinating women
who are like opposites and yet peas in a
pod and their beautiful friendship which
is one that has its ins and outs but is
built on unconditional love and
understanding of one another and I
couldn't have done it without them as
resources because they're just so Lively
and so funny and so interesting getting
on on the phone and on Zoom with them in
the early days of writing the script I I
just I think I still have like 50 pages
of Diana and Bonnie dialogue in some
document on my computer where they're
like debating Carl Sean and and and
discussing what to write in a note to a
friend whose dog died like they just are
so verbal they're they know each other
in their bones and it's the kind of
characters you you dream of finding as a
writer I was familiar with her story I
remembered it but but it was really the
producers who I have to thank for for
bringing me in because Teddy and Andrew
had the writes to her book and had been
thinking about this story for a while
and then had had gotten these incredible
directors so when I got the submission
and it was chai and Jimmy I was a fan of
their work like everyone else and it
revealed itself to me to be this really
interesting character portrait and and
friendship portrait so it was an easy s
so I do want to talk to the producers
because I understand you were first on
board this when did you first remember
you know I don't know if you like me saw
the story on the news and it it struck a
court or maybe you'd been following
Diana's career all along and and how did
you know you know that Not only would it
make a great story but to sort of focus
on this one chapter of her
career um I love the book I mean I I I
remember when she did the swim but it
wasn't until I read her myem more that I
fell in love with the story because the
book was incredibly well written and I
had a um Studio deal and I had to show
the book to at a first look and they
said no we can't do that movie and I'm
like oh my God you're crazy this is the
best so for me it's about I love this
idea that you should never give up I
just think that that's like we all we
should all you don't need to have a big
dream like this or a crazy dream like
this but dream big like dream or don't
let go of your dreams so for me it was
just about the like it was obvious it
leapt off the page that it was very
cinematic and an incredible inspiring
story you know we had the opportunity to
meet Diana um knew the story a little
bit and as you sort of see in the film
Diana is a force she is unrelenting
she's driven um she's incredibly
charismatic and passionate and um her
belief in herself really inspires uh a
belief in those around her we're not
doing Chariots of Fire um we are not um
trying to just glorify a depiction of
someone who's done something that
frankly deserves glorification but how
do we distill this down to something um
a little more specific a little more
nuanced that was in partnership with uh
with Julia uh in partnership with chai
and Jimmy and what they brought and and
then obviously Alexon and and claudo and
the entire team that came together to
try and do something that's that's
greater than the whole um which
obviously goes without saying wouldn't
be possible without Anette Benning and
and Jody Foster and Alexandra you you
you've provided music for so many
different gen genres of film what I mean
I just imagine you have your choice of
any projects what specifically Drew you
to this one it was just obvious when I
saw the film it
was the direction I mean everything is
is so incredible photography and the
actors we we've been talking about anet
and and Jody which who are amazing but
uh re fans who's the third of the trio
who brings so much Humanity so you know
it's rare to see to be offered a movie
where everything seems to be you know
falling in the right place um and that
was it we have asked Alexander to score
every single film we've ever made makes
sense
sorry Ed used his music as temp for
every single movie we've ever made um
and this was just a dream come true I
couldn't have imagined the score that
Alexander composed even after living
with this material for so long but it
was like the film found its like I don't
know partner its soul in some way it's
it's just it was really cool and we feel
very lucky as you say the difficult
thing is to find soul of the film what
is the what are what is the music here
for what what can I do to help you know
to make the film even better or more
beautiful or more emotional and uh
that's where you start and as the
characters were so strong first of all
of course NAD she's a as you say she's
such a force of nature that you have to
think about her how can you give her
something else if the music is too
strong well you're killing her
performance it's a lot of work but it's
easy when the mov movies that uh
perfect wow can I say that yes perfect
please do
good um claudo uh you're obviously you
won an Academy Award for your work on
Life of Pi which is also set largely on
water but very different obviously um
can you talk about the specific
challenges of this film particularly
this this stunning underwater
photography that was a lot of work man
uh um it just it just dealing with the
water and how we were going to shoot it
was all kind of challenges to bring a
new way to look at someone swimming and
there so new things in technology allow
us to get really close to the actors
versus big giant systems so I had the
idea of just having a system that was
sort of simple and easy to use with
actors and I feel like that gets you
kind of more in their head and I think
it was really important to get close to
Diana as she's swimming and to really
get and I think that does connect you to
the soul of the movie figure out the
method of how we're um going to move the
camera and and lighting and how we're
going to deal with lighting and coming
up with the red strip that we saw on
some of the documentaries this is the
way we're going to light almost the
whole water scene at night so it just
kept it really kind of simple and I
wanted the boat to be really
self-contained and I worked you know
hard to kind of figure out the coverage
of you know where Bonnie sits and where
Reese is and and and or so there's like
this triangle between the three that the
as a story and when you're shooting it
that we could shoot this and connect the
three people on this Voyage working with
with Jimmy and chai was was kind of
amazing because you could just bring up
ideas but it was just interesting ways
to look at the film and and I try to
give as much as I can for a movie that
takes a little long swimming different
viewpoints some of this sounds almost
experimental a little experimental in
some things you know with water and like
you know and just just in general with
the whole boat and the and our little
you know tank that we had he he did
build the SS Miranda which is this idea
that he had early on about how are we
going to shoot someone swimming in a
different Manner and so it's like a
submersible unit that you could put a
camera in so you could see the water
line but you weren't in the water and we
would have it on the track tracking with
an nette and there's a a couple shots in
there that you see and um that was very
experimental in fact when we shot it
remember we we we we we did the first
couple takes and we were like oh it
worked but I didn't realize this little
idea would weigh you know 10,000 lbs
Taiwan built clao a tank for you know
for Life of Pi and the way I described
it was like he had like a Formula 1 car
and then with us he had like Roller
Skates um and it he has the incredible
team and he runs such a type chip and
like he was also handed to directors who
are like oh no we've done everything the
Himalaya yeah no ropes caves and then
you know you have over 30 days of water
tank work which we were not necessarily
prepared for initially and claudo made
sure like we got it and it was also
Anette who had trained so hard for that
year that she could stay in the water
for hours can we talk a little bit more
about this cast because they're so phen
phal and you're coming out of the gate
with you know working with water doing a
period piece and like I'm going to say
three of the best actors ever was it
ever intimidating or on our very first
day of filming and there's you know
hundreds of people on
set and jod Foster is out on a boat like
100 feet away and we do our first take
and I and we have to give notes on a
mega phone in front of like 400 people
to jod Foster that's our first
day on set um yeah that was a little
intimidating but they're all so
fantastic I I mean I can't even imagine
um and I I think we have someone here
with us today you maybe wanted to point
out um we have a very special guest here
tonight um the real life Bonnie stall
can you stand up and just wave um and we
to call badass Bonnie badass Bonnie
badass Bonnie here's the badass
[Applause]
Bonnie well I want to remind everyone
that this movie is actually going to be
in Select theaters next weekend I
believe October 20th um before
premiering on Netflix on November 3rd
it's such a special film I want to thank
you so much for being here thank you all
for being a great audience thank you
thank you it's like a dream come true to
be here so thank you thank you to our
amazing
team
that